hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my agents of shield season 3
finale video they took two episodes and
jammed them together so it was a
two-hour finale but technically it was
two episodes so just careful for
spoilers here we go instead of doing the
normal top ten I'm just going to do
Easter eggs and talk about what I think
is going on in season four they did a
really good job with the six month jump
forward of giving you a preview of what
season four is going to look like or
what's going to be happening when they
first pick up
so basically hive is gone the way they
explained it Bret Dalton's character the
risen Ward / - as his Lincoln's
character so Lincoln took one for the
team the way they explained it is the
Daisy believed that she was the person
that was supposed to be on there I don't
know if that was ever a possibility I
feel like it wasn't it feels like the
way Luke's Ark was set up this season is
that he has this troubled past
he's trying to do this to be the Jesus
of the group he's taking all the group's
sins as they explained it he's paying
for all our sins he took all their sins
on his shoulders and died just the way
Jesus did so heavy-handed religious
themes just like daredevil season 2 if
you haven't watched it yet daredevil
season 2 was amazing but because
Catholicism is such a big part of the
Matt Murdock character there are always
a lot of heavy-handed religious themes
in daredevil stories but they also kind
of introduce that idea with the plot of
the finale as well as the yo-yo
character talking about having faith we
salute you Lincoln Jesus for taking the
warhead in the butt for the team
humanity thanks you and Hellfire thanks
you for not turning all the women of the
earth into people that he doesn't want
to have sex with
maybe we can tweak the formula down the
line the Hellfire characters slowly
growing on me we'll see how much he
comes back in season 4 most of these
drags in the episode are actually season
4 Easter eggs the one that I'm going to
be talking about you all probably
spotted Princess Leia Coulson help me
obi-wan Kenobi you're my only hope
there's always going to be a lot of Star
Wars going on in everything Marvel in
almost anything sci-fi but far and away
best performance of the episode was this
Coulson fake-out it was you know very
Joss Whedon type moment like you
remember at the end of season 1 /
Coulson walks in and just a liquefies
Garrett like it's no big deal oh so
that's what it does
so best performance of the episode and
probably one of the best performances of
the entire season this is like Coulson's
killer five minutes stand up set he
should have gone on tour in that six
month period but we got to talk about
season four Easter eggs so
right off the bat they jump six months
forward that was intentional they always
do a time jump between seasons of agents
of shield
they said they decided to do the time
jump early just to say hey this is
what's going to be happening when we
pick up in season four so I'm gonna
describe these Marvel Easter eggs in the
beats that they hit using other movies
and TV shows that you guys can go watch
right now to give you a pretty good idea
for where they're taking inspiration for
these big story beads so number one life
model decoy ex machina if you haven't
seen ex machina
it's a story all about freewill what is
humanity what is evolution what is
consciousness is this really amazing
movie with amazing actors make sure you
watch it so clearly that's where I think
they're headed with this life model of
decoy arc where the AI will attain a
certain level of consciousness vision
style in the season we'll explore what
it means to be human and from a comic
book perspective if you don't know
anything about life model decoys most
people just know them from the movies
because of that Robert Downey jr. joke
life model decoys are actually a
creation of the comics they debuted in
1965 in strange tales number 135 Nick
Fury creates a bunch of life model
decoys through shield so they go way way
back they use them in a really
interesting twist during the original
sin storyline that was a big Nick Fury
storyline it was an 8 part series you
can get away with just reading the 8
issues of that you don't have to read
the tie-ins but it's all about Nick Fury
investigating the death of the watcher
but there's a huge life model decoy
twist in it
relative to Nick Fury that goes back to
the 1960s they do a really interesting
way of invoking Marvel history in it on
the other side of that you have Skye's
storyline who now looks like she's on
the run she's doing the mr. robot thing
where she's sticking it to the man like
tearing down banks trying to help people
but she's not part of a big organization
she's left shield so Coulson's trying to
bring her in because she's very powerful
Coulson on the other hand is operating a
lot like Iron Man is at the end of
Captain America Civil War so careful for
spoilers from Captain America Civil War
I judge you for not having seen it if
you haven't seen it yet go see it right
now but Coulson is operating under
another director so he's no longer
director of shield I'll be interested to
see who that person is it could be
someone that we've seen before it could
be somebody totally new but I think he's
going to get to have a lot more fun now
that he's not the director of shield
anymore
he gets to be the Coulson that you
remember from the movies the guy who
just going all over the place tracking
people down getting to have all the fun
so he's not stuck in an office so the
homework list for agents of shield
season four is watching ex machina mr.
robot season 1 season 2 should be out
pretty soon too and reading Marvel's
original sin but the Daisy stuff it's
not totally clear who this little girl
is who her father was that Daisy made
the promise to to help out to help their
family very clearly she's operating like
she was pre season one before Coulson
took her in to shield where she's trying
to help people but she's doing it by
herself in isolation her powers are a
little bit stronger that actually looks
like the Smallville take off when they
had Clark fly on Smallville for the
first time the special effects for that
looked very similar to what Daisy is
doing right now but no she cannot fly
she can just jump really high so think
Superman leaping tall buildings in a
single bound but that's pretty much it I
think they have some good things going
into season 4 it should be pretty
exciting I haven't decided whether or
not I'm going to do videos for it but
I'll at least do videos for the first
couple of episodes I know a lot of you
guys freaked out when I was like maybe I
might stop doing videos for agents of
shield just due to a lack of interest
but that's never really a thing until it
actually happens like if we get to next
season and I make a video for it then
I'm still making videos for it I don't
know when they're going to be dropping
footage for season 4 it might be Comic
Con it might be the end of the summer
but if you're wondering Kevin Feige did
say that they're still planning on doing
an Inhumans movie way way down the road
they're just waiting for the right story
that just means that it's not a big
priority right now so there is still
inhuman stuff happening in the movies
meaning that the Royal Family's probably
still off-limits for the TV show but let
me know what did you guys think of the
finale and are you excited you know
based on that teaser from the end all
the life model decoy stuff are you
excited for season 4 you may have seen
on social media the actress that plays
Daisy Chloe Bennet she seems like a
totally cool person but she said she
feels like Marvel you know from a
corporate perspective the film guys are
treating the TV people like redheaded
stepchildren ending on a corporate level
Marvel doesn't really care about this
shared universe that the movies and the
TV shows existed she's not totally wrong
but I did think it was kind of funny
that she was coming out and saying like
hey movie people pay attention to us
more so remains to be seen how the TV
shows are going to work with the movies
going forward but for the most
part it's a one-way relationship where
the TV shows acknowledge what's going on
in the movies but the movies don't
necessarily acknowledge what's going on
in the TV shows don't expect that to
change anytime soon but there's a new
episode of arrow tonight there is a
finale for legends of tomorrow so just
I'll talk about DC stuff when I post my
arrow video tonight just to keep them
both separate so arrow video posting
later tonight why you guys wait for my
life model decoy to post that video
tonight you can click here for all my
Captain America Civil War Easter eggs
and you can click here to learn about
what's going on with that next
spider-man movie thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight